what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today is a great day because we have
some new official photos from spiderman
no way home and we have tom holland
himself talking about some scenes in the
movie what it was like filming some of
these scenes one scene in particular the
scene with doc ock alfred molina
returning to play the character what
that was like and what it was like
filming with zendaya and jacob battle on
again and the heartbreak that they all
felt not knowing if this actually was
going to be the last spider-man film
that they filmed together while at the
same time tom holland talks about how
confident he was in filming spider-man
knowing home along with director john
watts and how much fun they had filming
this movie and last but not least tom
holland talks about if they did do
another spider-man film or franchise
after the no way home trilogy it would
have to be very different than what they
are doing now and i'll deep dive into
all of this in this video and if you're
new and you want to stay up to date on
all things spider-man knowing home be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so first and
foremost this is all coming from
entertainment entertainmentweeklyew.com
and they did release two new steals from
spiderman no way home and of course we
will talk about these first now the
first one is actually kind of funny it's
of spider-man and mj now if you pay
attention to mj's clothes and spider-man
spidey suit you can notice that these
are actually the exact same outfits that
they were wearing at the end of
spider-man far from home in the
post-credits scene so this picture that
we're looking at right here is most
likely at the very beginning of the film
it's no doubt going to take place right
after the events of spider-man fire from
home right after mysterio reveals that
peter parker is spider-man this is most
likely right after jjj gets done talking
on the mega screen then everybody's
going to turn and look at spider-man and
then he's going to grab mj and get out
of there and as we know from the
post-credits scene mj did not really
like web slinging that much and in this
one it looks like he's free falling for
some period of time before he slings
that web and she just looks like she's
having a great time now the next photo
that we get is really really good we get
another photo of spider-man and doctor
strange what appears to be right outside
of the sanctum and strange just looks
really fed up with peter like come on
kid what are you doing here and if you
notice he is still wearing that red and
black spiderman suit so this most likely
is taking place during the first half of
the film as well this is probably either
right before or right after he goes to
doctor strange and asks him to do that
spell where everybody can forget that
peter parker is spider-man now there's
absolutely zero context to these photos
however if i look at this photo with
spider-man and doctor strange i kind of
feel like it's a very particular scene i
kind of feel like this is right after
some villains are let loose and the
multiverse kind of starts to go in the
chaos since we see peter parker in
normal clothes in the trailer inside of
the sanctum asking doctor strange to do
the spell and in this photo he is in his
spider-man outfit i want to say that
this is after doctor strange does the
spell also not to mention wang is
nowhere to be seen and if something was
going on outside wong would definitely
be there checking it out so i'm assuming
that this is after strange does the
spell and we know that spider-man kind
of messes up the spell or as dr strange
says he tampers with it and now it looks
like that tampering kind of caused
things to go wrong and now they're
dealing with the repercussions and this
could be why doctor strange is pretty
fed up with spider-man in this photo his
arms are crossed and he's looking at him
kind of like you see what you did kid
also at this point we kind of know that
the villains are going to be kept inside
of a magical prison cell inside of the
sanctum that strange is holding them in
and as rumor has it spider-man is
actually going to let these villains
free whether on purpose or accident or
whether it was with the spell we don't
know at this point but that could be
what we're seeing right here he let all
of the villains go and that could be the
reason that strange is pretty pissed
right here hopefully we'll find out a
little bit more when that trailer comes
and hopefully we're getting that within
about a month now but with these photos
like i mentioned came interviews with
tom holland and him speaking up about
some certain parts of the film and the
first thing we're going to talk about is
his scene with alfred molina tom holland
talks about filming with alfred molina
and keep in mind the last time that
alfred molina filmed as doc ock was in
2004 that's when spider-man 2 came out
which also means that he probably filmed
in 2003 as well that means alfred molina
played doc almost 20 years ago and it's
been almost 20 years since he acted like
doc ock and here's what tom holland had
to say about filming with alfred molina
he said it was really fun to watch him
see how technology has advanced when he
was making these films the arms were
puppets and when we did it they're all
imaginary and cg it was quite cool to
see him relive it but also relearn it
and i also love how they're just
throwing alfred molina right at us it's
not a secret that he's in the film
obviously anymore he came out and said
he was in the film before the first
trailer even came out and then they
showed him plain sight in the first
trailer now he goes on to talk about how
confident he was in filming this movie
and how much fun him and director john
watts had he says the first film john
watts and i were sort of flying by the
seat of our pants this one i think we
both felt really confident so we were
able to relax we actually had so much
more fun on this one than we did on the
previous two and i'm sure that comes
down to confidence but i'm also sure
that it comes down to having a lot of
different big actors to work with in
this film if you're catching what i'm
saying alfred molina willem dafoe jamie
foxx perhaps paul giamani and of course
what we're hoping for toby maguire and
andrew garfield and hopefully they are
coming because it sounds like the future
of spider-man is kind of unknown at this
point and no way home could be it for
tom holland now i seriously doubt that
he loves playing the character and
marvel loves him and sony loves him and
they have a great relationship now and i
don't think that's coming to an end
anytime soon but in this article he's
leading us to believe like he doesn't
know what's going to happen next he said
we were all treating no way home as the
end of a franchise let's say i think if
we're lucky enough to dive into these
characters again you'd be seeing a very
different version it would no longer be
the homecoming trilogy we would give it
some time and try to build something
different and tonally change the films
whether that happens or not i don't know
but we were definitely treating no way
home like it was coming to an end and it
felt like it he goes on to say we've
been making these films for five years
now we've had such an amazing
relationship the three of us we've been
with each other every step of the way
obviously talking about zendaya and
jacob battle on and himself he continues
to say we've done every single film
every single press tour so this one
scene we didn't know if this would be
the last time we were all working
together it was heartbreaking but also
really exciting because we're all moving
into the next chapter of our careers so
sharing that moment with them was maybe
the best day i've ever had on set i
don't think i've ever cried like that
ever but in the article for
entertainment weekly it says still tom
holland adds that just because he's
spent the last five years perfecting his
web singing didn't mean that he could
let himself get complacent tom holland
said if you're not willing to focus and
do the prep work you're going to get
called out because when you're dealing
with magical spells and dimensions it
really gets complicated now when tom
holland talks about the end of the
homecoming franchise and trilogy i think
that's exactly what he's talking about
the end of the homecoming trilogy do i
think he's coming back as spider-man yes
absolutely and i think he's actually
going to lead the avengers the new
avengers or possibly the young avengers
and i do think the homecoming trilogy
will end but a new one will begin but i
will say even though sony and marvel
have not confirmed that andrew garfield
and toby maguire are going to be in the
film i really really hope they do and
all of the evidence points to them being
in the film and if this truly is the
last time that we're going to see tom
holland on screen i think it's actually
going to be really really cool to not
only see him but see the spider-man that
came before him him standing right next
to toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man and then at the end
standing right next to mj and ned i
don't think this is the last time we'll
see tom hall into spider-man but i do
think that there will probably be some
time in between spider-man films after
this and i do think that this film is
going to be truly truly epic but let me
know what you think about all of this in
the comments down below what do you
think about these new photos and what do
you think about what tom holland said
about this possibly being the end leave
all your thoughts comments hopes dreams
tears in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter i did post these
photos on their first so if you want to
stay up to date live follow me there and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you